what is going on everybody welcome to
the second Q&A video I was just
absolutely blown away by the responses
from the first QA there's no way I can
get to answering all of those questions
in this video but my plan is to just do
weekly Q&A s and hopefully we can slowly
whittle away at questions if you have
new questions feel free to leave them on
this video if I don't answer your
question from the last video don't worry
I saw it if I plan to answer it I will
still answer it so getting into this
video first of all since I know some
people are just going to ask this back
here is a really old guitar it's
probably like 90 years old so almost a
century old it did I've removed the
bridge from it the bridge was just
coming up basically the needs to be
reglued so I got a sand that down we
glue it the strings held a tune for
about 30 seconds they were probably also
at least half a century old and then the
tuning mechanism is just really old
corroded and has a bunch of oxidation
and stuff so anyway I'm going to clean
it up
restring it and stuff and have a new
guitar so that's that
to answer the question someone else also
asked about like woodworking oh because
of the thing in the back I actually do
mess around mess around with woodworking
but I am NOT a woodworker by any means
we me and my wife sometimes get pallets
and we build things out of like the
pallets so we've built like some chairs
tables like a coffee mug hanging thing
stuff like that but we're not a
woodworkers we're just hobbyist and
sometimes we play with power tools so
anyway the main theme of the questions
I'm actually gonna be answering today is
on education so I got a lot of questions
about my own personal education as well
as my thoughts on like education in
general like going to college and CS
degrees and stuff like that so first of
all my personal education background I
went to Sam Houston State University I
had no idea what I wanted to do with
college I just had no aspiration really
when I was like 17 18 when you're
actually deciding on where to go to
college and a little bit further back
about me I was a student who just never
did homework so I did well enough on
tests and I would do projects but I just
didn't do homework I didn't like doing
homework so I just never did it never
turned it
but I was good enough on tests so I was
like a BNC student basically and I did
good on the SATs so or the SAT and was
good enough to just get automatically
accepted into Sam Houston State
University which was just like 45
minutes north of where I lived since I
had no idea what the heck I wanted to do
anyway I thought okay I'll just go there
so I went there started my degree is
criminal justice found out really
quickly this isn't for me and decided to
change my degree but I had basically
already done all the core classes so it
just seemed to make sense like let's go
ahead and keep that CJ degree and I'll
just add another major so I just double
majored CJ in philosophy so the
philosophy is basically what I did for
the rest that took up most of my
electives and then for my remaining
electives I just took economics courses
so that's my personal educational
background and then basically
programming came in around my junior
year so when I was about 21 is when I
found Python I had actually tried
programming way earlier in my life and
just did not like it sometimes I would
make cool designs on my ti-83 calculator
just out of boredom in class but I just
that was probably the extent of my
programming I tried to learn programming
before I was 21 but I had never found
Python I wonder what would have changed
in my life if I'd found Python earlier
that question is how important is
college and then the next part is why
Python maybe I'll talk about why Python
later but basically that's the answer is
just because I fell in love with Python
I tried other languages I did not like
them Python is just there's something
special at least for me or to me about
Python I would really like to learn C++
now it's just that my the actually use
cases like where I would use C++ is so
specific that I'm just not really
confident that it would be worth my
effort but maybe C++ in my future will
see how important is College though I
think College I'm not one of these
people that thinks College is worthless
I think College has so many extra values
that people never really consider but I
do think a lot of people waste money on
college so again just like me when I was
was it was college the right thing for
me at age 18 I really don't think so
maybe by when I was 21
22 or something like that I was more
prepared to like know what I wanted to
go to college for but I think a lot of
people aren't prepared like I wasn't and
in which case college is worth a little
bit less because here's the thing about
college that I think has the most value
it is networking and meeting like-minded
people and maybe you call that the same
thing but I don't necessarily just
networking is like meeting people in the
field who you can maybe call upon later
to help you get somewhere maybe or
something like that I mean some of
networking is just making friends and
stuff like that but there's like
networking for to help you later on in
life I suppose and then there's meeting
like-minded people to kind of help you
now maybe you want to work with these
people maybe wanna start business with
these people or maybe you just these are
just friends because you guys are
like-minded people whereas for me at Sam
Houston State I really just didn't click
with anyone they're like these were not
my kind of people
so it just it was not the greatest place
for me to go but I did not know where
else to go
and it's still kind of unclear to me
whether it would have been a better idea
to do anything else though besides go to
college because going to college is that
a good thing about going to college is
just getting away from from home getting
away from your comfort getting away from
your parents taking care of everything
for you getting away from like a an area
that you know so kind of like putting
yourself in this new and unfamiliar area
and getting out of your comfort zone has
a lot of value so next is uh my thoughts
on formal CS education so as I've made
clear I have no formal CS education and
also let me just stress - I mean this is
just like my thoughts I'm just some dude
on YouTube that programs so I'm not like
a career advice kind of person so so
these are just these are my own opinions
so don't definitely don't go based on
what I'm saying but anyway for formal CS
education
I actually think nowadays formal CS is
is actually getting getting to the point
where it's it's acceptable but I will
say CS computer science does not equal
programming a lot of times people will
have that misconception but a lot of
times you're not actually going to get
very much programming in a CS degree
that seems to be changing now but you're
going to get a whole lot of other stuff
that you may not be interested in and
for some reason most universities don't
have like a program
degree they have they're just CS degrees
but it seems like CS is slowly morphing
into actually being just a programming
degree and a lot less on true computer
science i point well here in my computer
but you can't see it so anyway there's
that also I think part of the problem
with university education is a lot of
times it's outdated just a fact oh by
the time you get a professor this is
someone who has been in the field
sometimes you can get a professor who's
currently in the field but it's pretty
rare so usually they've retired or
something they've left the field and now
they're just teaching the same thing
year after year and that works for many
fields but it doesn't work for Science
and Technology okay and some other
fields but mostly like science and
anything the science and technology it's
not going to work okay
so you have to update every year and a
lot of times I ask people like what are
they doing and their CS degree and then
of course they learned some Python but
what version of Python is it it's like
2.5 all right it's like what like that's
just absurd it's got to be either 2 7 or
3 plus and the only reason 2 7 would be
acceptable is if the professor is
currently in the field and using 2 7
that's just what they know that's what
they're going to teach but otherwise
they should be teaching three point five
or three point six right now those are
the only two choices so anyway that's my
only complaint with CS is just mostly if
you when you're pant and you're paying
somebody for this so it's really
important that they get it right but
with with all things like cut just
college in general and CS 2 is doing the
college path is just one of the paths
it's not a necessary path it's just one
of them especially for CS employers
really don't care that much whether or
not you have a CS degree they want to
see proof that you know what you say you
know so github and a portfolio of some
kind that isn't just github because a
lot of initial hiring managers so these
like technical or they call technical
sorcerers or something they typically
don't know programming so when they're
looking through profiles of people
generally this seems to occur on
LinkedIn a lot they're looking through
profiles of people they want to be able
to click something and like see it
visually right because again these are
not programmer people their technical
sorcerer's
and they never know program I've never
met a technical sorcerer that knew
anything about programming so it's
really important that you'll not only
have a github but something that can
show what you know so anyway for formal
CS education the only thing I guess that
I would say is like if you have a degree
from like MIT or Stanford or something
like that it's probably less important
that you have something for sure that
you can show but I think it really does
still stand there
the final question I wanna answer is
this one part two we'll just have to
leave for a future discussion but the
first part how is criminology and
philosophy helps you in your career life
aspirations etcetera there's a lot of
things here but I don't want to just
talk for the next 30 minutes the biggest
thing is just perspectives so with
criminology and criminal justice it's
getting the perspective from the law
enforcement side so most people's
interaction with law enforcement slike
always like this adversarial kind of
interaction right you're on the defense
they're on the offense and like you're
getting pulled over for speeding your
neighbor called in noise violation the
cops are at your door so I'm like that's
always just unpleasant
so for most people they oh that's their
version of what law enforcement is but
if you ever get the opportunity to
somehow meet these people and see their
side of things your perspective changes
a lot so for example if you ever get the
opportunity where you have a reason to
ask for one ask for a ride-along with
just some some police department
somewhere hopefully like in a city or
something like that where something
actually happens and I think that's a
really good experience I'm pretty sure
you don't need anything besides the
ability to sign a waiver basically sign
away your life because you could get
into some hairy situations but anyways
um that's criminal justice philosophy
the same thing it's just perspective
right like if you if you read like some
Plato or something like that you'll
realize that the problems that we have
today are really the same problems that
we had hundreds or even thousands of
years ago it's the same stuff
it's just repeating all right and so I
think that perspective is really
valuable also yeah we probably have time
the biggest thing I think I learned from
both of them I can't remember which
course it was in
if it was criminology or philosophy but
where I went to schools Huntsville Texas
smack in the middle of like three
prisons
and we do have capital punishment here
in Texas and people are executed at I
don't know I forget the name of the
prison there but one of those prisons
does it and so the topic of capital
punishment comes up a lot both in
philosophy and criminal justice usually
some sort of ethics or something like
that and probably the most profound
thing I learned in all of college was
when we were discussing capital
punishment being for or against capital
punishment one of the students raised
their hand and this is more well known
nowadays but it wasn't back then and
even today's people still make a mistake
but usually get corrected and this this
kid raised his hand and states that he's
for capital punishment because it's
cheaper to just kill them than it is to
house these abhorrent criminals for life
like feed them take care of their
medical and all that kind of stuff right
so putting aside this kind of fiscal
reasoning to kill somebody we can just
set that aside and we could debate that
later the real issue or the real
profound thing is that actually it's
wrong because actually to kill someone
it's more expensive than to house them
for life because well we're killing
someone here and there is a lot of
litigation in the form of Appeals so
before we kill someone there's a very
large appeals process it's very
expensive to kill somebody because we
want to make sure that we're killing the
right person and that they actually do
deserve to be killed right this is an
important thing so what what just
fascinated me was that someone was able
to have an opinion a strong opinion a
firm opinion enough to voice it to an
audience of like 200 people in a you
know an auditorium and decide that
they're going to kill somebody
to save money because it's good it just
it just has to be right you just think
about it just got to be cheaper that way
but it turns out they're actually wrong
and the opposite is true and this is
such an important thing and this happens
probably all of the time it's not just
on capital punishment it's on a whole
bunch of issues that we just formulate
our opinions on things to mutually
because it like it sounds right in our
head but we're not actually checking and
I think
like a really important attribute of
just just human nature in general that
you really don't want to ever forget
about yourself and others that we have
this this problem basically in
formulating opinions but anyway luckily
nowadays it does seem that more people
are aware that that's it's actually more
expensive to kill people and stuff like
that and hopefully not everybody has
this opinion like let's just do the
cheapest thing possible but anyway I
thought that was probably probably the
most interesting event that ever
occurred or the thing that I learned the
most from from college anyway on that
lovely note I'm going to close out the
second QA if you have more new questions
or whatever feel free to leave them
below I'll be happy to answer them in a
future Q&A video otherwise I will see
you in the next video